john constantine has a long history
across every version of dc's expansive
universe but what are his true origins
and was he actually the reason swamp
thing was able to have a daughter stay
tuned to find out
before we get into the in-universe
history of dc's unluckiest mystic it's
worth taking a look at the
behind-the-scenes story of how he came
to be
after all while most of the uk's famous
fictional spellcasters descend from the
tradition of merlin our boy john was
inspired by a very different british
hero gordon sumner better known to the
world as sting the story behind john
constantine's first appearance in 1985's
swamp thing number 37 is pretty simple
when writer alan moore asked artists
steven bessette and john totalben what
they'd like to draw they told him they
wanted to draw sting or at least someone
who looked like him
moore thought sting's striking look
would work for the charismatic
manipulative magician that he had in
mind and thus john constantine stepped
onto the page as for the specific visual
references that bessette and total ben
were drawing from the long coat and suit
look that would become john
constantine's trademark was inspired by
sting's appearance in 1979's
quadrophenia based on the who album of
the same name another inspiration though
was much more esoteric a 1982 tv movie
called brimstone and tree cull where
sting played a disturbing fourth wall
breaking character who may or may not
have been the devil pretty fitting all
things considered saying that john
constantine has had a rough life is
putting things mildly there are very few
characters in comics who've had quite as
much misery heaped on them over the
years in john's case as revealed in
hellblazer number 39 it started even
before he was born as a child jon
occasionally had visions of what he
called the golden boy he was essentially
just that an imaginary friend made up of
shining golden light that john both
loved and hated for his seeming
perfection
after he grew up though jon learned that
he was neither imaginary nor a friend
but a parallel world echo of the twin
brother he never knew he had the
existence of a twin wasn't just news to
him the doctors who delivered jon as a
baby were also pretty surprised when it
turned out that mary ann constantine had
been pregnant with a second child the
other brother was so sickly and
underweight that he'd gone unnoticed
unfortunately he had been strangled in
the womb and neither he nor mary
survived the birth the surviving infant
of course was john
his childhood was marked by intense
hatred and resentment from his father
who made it very clear that he wished
john had been the one who died instead
john and his father thomas constantine
didn't get along while john was growing
up
not only did thomas blame jon for mary's
death but he was also disappointed in
him for other reasons tom wanted a
normal son who would fit in with the
other kids at school rather than a young
weirdo who spent all his time on books
about magic and demons
the elder constantine burned a stack of
his son's books and a fit of anger
hoping to drive him away from sorcery
this might have worked out for the best
but jon was furious he decided to get
back at his dad so he cursed him by
binding his soul to a dead cat
before long thomas was wasting away from
an inexplicable disease as the feline
corpse rotted but jon was left feeling
guilty about what he'd done to his old
man
since the spell couldn't be reversed he
preserved the cat in formaldehyde
stopping his father from degenerating
any further cut to a few decades later
and thomas finally died only for his
soul to be stuck on earth he terrified
john's niece gemma until jon realized
that as long as the preserved cat was
around thomas would be bound by it and
would continue suffering to free him jon
dug up the cat from under his mother's
tombstone where he buried it he then
burned the corpse finally setting his
father free if john constantine has an
origin story in the traditional
superhero sense then it's what went down
with the newcastle crew's disastrous
attempt to help a young girl the gory
details are in hellblazer number 11 and
they are not for the faint of heart it
happens early on in john's career as a
freelance magician when he hears about
some bad stuff going down at the
casanova club the club's owner was
involved with the same sort of shady
magic scene as jon but his proclivities
were far more disturbing including the
abuse of his daughter astra logue
eventually astra manifested a monster
called norfolk thing and after being
summoned the norfolk thing does to the
club owner and his guests exactly what
they did to astra it also tore off their
heads and turned the basement of the
casanova into a carnal house to deal
with the norfolk thing jon gathered six
other occultists to form the newcastle
crew from there he came up with the
not-so-brilliant plan of summoning a
powerful demon to kill astra's monster
but when john found out what was
happening with the girl
he decided
was gonna
it did not go well while the ritual was
correct constantine got the wrong name
for the demon since the name is the
thing that provided the control he
essentially unleashed a horrifying and
hungry force on himself his friends and
poor astra the demon nergal did destroy
the norfolk thing but it then turned on
jon and his friends jon was forced to
lead astra through hell itself in an
attempt to save her soul and while he
held tight to her hand for the whole
trip said hand didn't stay attached to
the rest of the girl she was dragged to
hell and the rest of the newcastle crew
was left traumatized they all met grisly
fates before their souls were condemned
to hell as for jon he managed to avoid
eternal damnation but he wound up
suffering his own personal health for
the next few years the contingency plan
for summoning the demon at the casanova
was one that we can probably all get
behind blowing it up with a very
enthusiastic round of arson
unfortunately for jon setting things on
fire tends to be very effective at both
solving problems and creating them when
this bizarre magician emerged from a
fire clutching a severed hand and
ranting about a demon that dragged him
to hell he wound up being taken to the
raven scar secure hospital a miserable
and disreputable asylum for the
criminally insane the chief problem for
constantine was that while he was
certainly traumatized he wasn't
hallucinating there was a demon that was
after his soul but the only thing that
the staff and inmates of ravensgaard
knew was that all this bad stuff
happened and jon was involved as a
result constantine was beaten by the
inmates and tortured by the doctors
under the guise of treatment with
electro-convulsive therapy being a
favorite tactic all of this only served
to amplify his self-loathing and the
guilt he felt for his plan going so
horrifically wrong as hellblazer number
50 put it in one of its typically
cheerful moments the only reason he
hated them was that they wouldn't cut
his throat and end the agony john's
tenure at ravenscar lasted two years but
the memory of both the events that led
him there and the treatment he received
in its walls would haunt him for the
rest of his life
like a lot of comic book characters
there are different versions of john
constantine's backstory depending on
what comics you're reading but his path
is weirder than most when he was
introduced in the pages of swamp thing
it was as part of the dc universe most
of his series however was published by
dc's vertigo imprint a line initially
focused on horror titles for adult
readers that was separated from the
bright super-heroic world of the main dc
comics
eventually after 20 years of being
sequestered in his own supernatural
universe constantine was folded back
into the dcu proper his origin was then
revised with a little less of the
disturbing darkness involved the new
origin story that led constantine to
join the justice league dark and deal
with the dc universe's magical threats
still wound its way through newcastle
astrolog's damnation and a stint in
ravenscar asylum this time though things
started to go bad much earlier in
constantine number 14 readers learned
that at a very young age john
encountered some sinister demonic force
that offered him magical power jon
eagerly accepted but as is usually the
case with this sort of thing he wasn't
told about the price of this power until
it was too late to do anything about it
the price in typically tragic fashion
was jon's home and family in his first
use of magic constantine burnt down his
childhood house standing untouched in
the center of the flames while his
mother and father were burned to death
in front of him there is one element of
constantine's pre-trench coat life
that's consistent among various versions
of the character before he started
skulking around in his iconic duster
manipulating swamp monsters into doing
his mysterious and vaguely sinister
bidding he was into some really
disreputable stuff rock and roll in his
younger days constantine under the not
so great stage name johnny conjob was
the lead singer in a punk band called
mucus membrane
according to constantine himself they
weren't very good when it came to the
actual music but their brief time in the
grotesque spotlights of british punk
clubs did see them find some success
of course that had a lot less to do with
their musical talent than it did with
the undeniable charisma of their front
man the reason that mucous membrane
broke up varies from one series to the
next in the current dc universe it was
prompted by constantine's use of magic
as part of his stagecraft it caused his
bandmate and lover veronica delacroix to
fade away from the physical world until
she became a disembodied spirit
in the classic vertigo comics it had
more to do with the newcastle incident
and john's subsequent commitment to
ravenskar at one point an amateur
documentary crew trying to find out what
happened to mucous membrane starred in a
story that ran through hellblazer number
245 to 246.
in this arc they were all violently
murdered by the remnants of asterisk
terror elemental the norfolk thing
another one of the more consistent
elements in constantine's life is his
romantic history with stage magician
legitimate sorceress and justice leaguer
zatana zatara
the backward talking spellcaster
predates jon's portrayal in comics by 20
years but their pasts have been depicted
as being intertwined since very early in
constantine's existence
see you all right
yeah as soon as you get off me
i should have known you were the reason
i'm not back in london enjoying a pint
sadly the way their lives are tangled
together is about as tragic as
everything else in constantine's past
while they do maintain some level of
affection for each other there is a
pretty big sticking point in their
history that prompted their initial
breakup constantine killed her dad
he didn't intentionally end john
zatara's life but he was the driving
force behind the magic ritual that
resulted in her father bursting into
flames and dying in front of them in the
original comics this was an attempt to
deal with the mystical side of the
multiverse shattering event seen in
crisis on infinite earths but a similar
event exists even in the current
continuity where the crisis didn't
happen before they broke up zatana cast
a spell on jon telling him you need to
be a better person though of course she
said it in her backward way of
spellcasting that would explain why
constantine is less of a loner and a bit
more eager to help these days wouldn't
it
constantine was originally introduced as
a supporting character for swamp thing
and while he's had plenty of success on
his own he's always had that association
there's another reason that those
characters will always be inextricably
linked though believe it or not the saga
of swamp thing is at its heart a romance
between the eponymous muk monster and
his wife abby arcane at one point after
the creation of a seed that would
combine swampy's plant-based essence
with a human soul abby and the swamp
thing decided to have a child of their
own the problem was that swamp thing was
not human and didn't have the right
equipment for the job what he did have
was the ability to take over someone
else's body using semi-mystical plant
spores and a person who owed him several
favors with that in mind swamp thing
took over john constantine's body flew
to louisiana and then used him to
impregnate abby with their daughter to
faye
after constantine manipulated him into
several dubious semi-sinister errands of
his own swamp thing felt justified in
his actions as a means to an end
the tree that swamp thing got tattooed
on constantine's rear end while he was
piloting the guy's body however was pure
revenge check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite comics are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you